[Applaudissements]
on la cache du bonheur
je jure ça m'émeut te demander si après
gérard depardieu après anne roumanoff
lundi il y aura pierre palmade eux vous
il va y avoir la semaine nationale
pierre palmade ary abittan on n'a qu'à
rice voilà donc une où il y aura bidal
aussi hassani qui sera avec nous j'ai eu
et bouder voilà je suis très heureux de
te voir
je suis très content parce que c'était
un super pote way ce soit tu es un pote
mais c'est aussi un invitée parce que
j'ai plein de choses à dire enfin je me
transforme en associant tuloup disent
des choses non mais sérieux tu vas
devoir non seulement parce qu'à ton
spectacle
ouais bien sûr qu'il faudra aller voir
ça va reprendre du jeudi au dimanche de
11 septembre bouder is back bouder qui
cartonne ça me fait tellement plaisir
mais vraiment voilà lancé non mais je te
jure bien mais ça me ferait un retour
soit tu sais pas parce que je t'aime
profondément ça fait des années que je
le connais depuis vingt ans ouais et
j'ai toujours su que tu étais un très
gros mois et a toujours été fidèle en
amitié aussi ça faut le dire tu me suis
dit ce qui m'a fait hyper plaisir c'est
que cet été à chaque fois que me balader
et jean bizet ou et booder parce que je
suis ton fils non mais
on a reçu de test ce matin le père oui
j'irai à marrakech jamais c'est vrai que
c'est vers là on se demande après toi
tout le temps veut l'héritage c'est ça
bah oui aussi un trek à billets à
gratter ne dirait pas non à bouder qui
vient nous voir pour un livre aussi
comme d'air on apprend plein de trucs
sur la mer à ce que vous ne tapez pas
l'habitude de cuivre et non mais non et
là tu te livre beaucoup
ouais non mais c'est vrai comme c est
vraiment changé j'ai trouvé ça top parce
que c'est toi qui résume le mieux le
livre que tu dis le but ce n'est pas de
vous raconter ma vie
le but c'est que je vous fasse
comprendre ma vie mes échecs mais
réussit mes conneries aussi on va pas se
mentir tout ce que je veux c'est vous
montrer qu'avec de la volonté on peut
arriver à tout et c'est ce que tu dis
alors tu reviens sur ta vie on apprend
plein de choses notamment à propos de ta
tu dis ta différence tu parles de ta
différence est aussi de ta naissance
très compliqué tu dis que le tout début
de ta vie était compliqué pour toi et ta
famille pourquoi pas parce que je suis
né au maroc en 1978 je suis né j'étais
un bébé qui est né avec avec un asthme
et à l'époque qu'on en 78 dans un
village marocain l'asthme on connaît pas
at war et le docteur quand les mamies
enfin le docteur qui était aussi
mécanicien et plein de couple entre du
nuage
il connaissait pas ça donc j'avais du
mal à respirer il à dire maintenant à un
moment où le débat cet enfant là
normalement si tout se passe bien il
passera pas l'hiver ça ouais voilà et
mon papa qui était ici en france et qui
travaillaient ici en france et il a dit
laurent cet enfant va vivre et puis et
puis voilà je raconte tout le
cheminement de ma maman jusqu'à paris
c'est le début du livre que c'est ça et
donc voilà et laurie je reviens sur ça
parce que c'est vrai que je profite de
nation émission aussi pour dire parce
que beaucoup de gens quand on va sur
internet honte à bouder interprète des
noms de maladies de fou non mais s'ils
voulaient il a le skip innogy la
latitude c'est ma tête je suis pas
malade
moi ça me fait rire mais malheureusement
j'ai beaucoup de mamans et beaucoup de
parents qui m'écrivent en me disant
voilà mon fils là la même maladie que
vous tuez moi je suis pas malade
c'est compliqué de mères en détresse que
t'es pas maladroit donc voilà je pense
alors ta maman elle part alors du maroc
elle arrive à paris pour rejoindre ton
père tu vas passer un nom à l'hôpital
d'ici là tu dis la france n'aura donné
mes premiers bouts d'oxygène exactement
c'est vrai que je le vois à chaque fois
tu aime profondément la france
bah je suis français ouais je sais mais
je suis aimé la roumanie j'ai rien à
voir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je sais parfois il ya des trucs que tu
vois en france qui te font de la peine
mais sinon mais j'aime bien sûr mais on
est français d'abord on a des origines
nation je choisis marocain je suis
citoyen du monde mais un français oui
parce qu'on a grandi en france on a
étudié en france on a tout fait en
france et ça me peine quand j'entends
nique la france par exemple trois
semaines c'est du mal parce que non
c'est vrai on est bien en france quand
même et je rage en compte dans mon
spectacle ou si tu vois et c'est en
france que j'ai eu beau mon premier
bouder atteint procès afin que j'ai les
axéens bouder et voilà en fait c'est ce
que je raconte dans le livre
tous ces airs qui ont été coupées par
des obstacles et à chaque fois qu'un
nouvel erp qui quittait alors il
faudrait que tu t'es tu faisais plein de
conneries quand tu étais petit c'est ce
que tu dis ouais j'ai été 7e dan de
conneries c'est quoi la plus grosse
connerie que des fêtes je peux pas la
raconter à la télé à des enfants dont
l'âge est fait beaucoup de bêtises
j'ai fait beaucoup de bêtises à l'école
je je aujourd'hui je regrette parce que
justement il a fallu que je reprenne la
vie des tables de multiplication à 30
ans ouais parce que je vois avec ton
fils ton film sera donc je suis papa
franchement il ya plein de plein de
bêtises que je regrette alors dans
l'étude revient aussi sur ton physique à
la taille les préjugés le regard des
autres qui en a joué beaucoup ton
physique taillé tunis est autiste qui a
fait son succès mais celui de moi j'ai
moi j'ai pas de souci avec cinq mois -
les gens ce qui m'a aidé en fait quand
tu grandis dans un quartier populaire
soit 6,7 bac soit 6 ème année
ouais bon moi je vend très bien 14,8
blagues sur ma tête et je faisais des
blagues sur la tête et donc c'est de
bonne guerre
bien sûr ce que je raconte dans mon
spectacle est dans le livre c'est aussi
une manière de dire aux gens bon bah il
faut s'accepter comme on est puis il
faut en rire et et voilà depuis la
france c'est celle des grands des petits
des oufs ludique à 12 ans tu joues au
foot en faisant passer pour un poussin
donc ça s'était passé huit ans plus tard
aussi sata éviter de contrôle dans les
transports ouais ouais il pas un conte
était petit bain sur matt avait pas
c'était la gratuité a bien sûr été
tranquille et quand il m'a arrêté je
leur disais toujours à j'ai perdu ma
carte je l'ait pas ramené et aux dés
d'ailleurs il ya peu de gens qui te
renvoie à ton physique tu dis je sens
bien que je fais marrer tout le monde
car tout le monde va être pote avec moi
on ne me renvoie jamais à la figure non
physique atypique au contraire je me
sens très populaire les gens veulent se
rapprocher de moi ouais bah dans tout
l'est tous les endroits où j'ai été
c'est que moi j'ai été connu avant
d'être connu enfin dans tous les
quartiers paris dans tous les quartiers
de banlieue et ses seins comme j'étais
éducateur puis assurer un footballeur
pas tous pourris les footballeurs
devraient se rencontrer plein de gens je
me suis fait plein de potes et quand je
suis devenu enfin quand j'ai commencé à
accéder à ce métier là tout le monde me
dit bon ça va aller finir comme iconix
est d'ailleurs tonton boudeur ouais
c'est par rapport à un footballeur
exactement à la digue de guerre voilà
que j'embrasse qui nous regardent
voilà un joueur marocain excellent
exemple moi ceci et c'est pour ça un
jour il a voulu floqué son maillot bah
en fait j'étais fan nazisme ou sarlat
taboulé et pour floquer les maillots tu
sais ça coûtait super cher donc
j'écrivais au stylo mois ouais et comme
bouderbala c'est long j'ai écrit que
bouder et dans le quartier ont appelé
blue d'air à cause de ça et ton vrai
prénom c'est mohamed exact bouder est
avec nous ce soir merci billère
tu du good hair moder tu dis que celui
qui va changer la vie
il sait qu'il est mais qui ont le plus
compté pourtant dans le métier je crois
qu'à mouss diouf leur place je suis pas
le seul parce qu'à après il ya des gens
mais mes mousse c'est le seul qui est
devenu vraiment au début mai et qui m'a
dit d'ailleurs même pour toi c'est sûr
souvient il dirigeait le général j'ai le
temps mais il avait le réservoir
c'est vrai que dans une des salles
mythiques de paris hemus c'était ça
c'était bon jour qui sait faire vire
vas-y monte sur scène et un jour il est
venu me voir via un ami à lui il est
venu voir mon spectacle et m'a dit voilà
moi j'ai 30 euros j'ai mise sur toi
alors si ça marche on va rigoler si ça
marche pas on voit encore plus à l'école
donc voila et ça a commencé comme ça et
puis et je lui dois beaucoup parce que
c'est dans ce métier tu as toujours
besoin de quelqu'un qui meurt comme toi
tu mets le pied à l'étrier à plein de
gens par mois ça a été mon bijou
vous assurez les jamais les croire à la
c1 merci en tout cas à bouder vous êtes
avec nous ou des bus verts
est ce que tu vas faire la grosse
rigolade avec moi le 22 septembre
s'obliger sinon ma mère anne me tape
basset et normalement je la fais mais je
sais dans tu dois jouer je joue à genève
ouais voilà je suis déjà complet là bah
ouais ils sont douze à l'âge plaisante
on est complet on espère jouer à genève
quand même parce que le public m'attend
là bas et si à une restriction à cause
du coc vide qui sera avec moi le 26
qu'elle a le mieux à deux chiffres est
là à 8 heures du matin je sais ma chérie